texas democrat henry cuellar toured the
border yesterday with other lawmakers uh
democrat a couple republicans sir
welcome back and thank you for joining
us on our program today
thank you so much listen i applaud the
fact that you have been so public trying
to help the people in texas
and the people who live in in your state
why is it so obvious that the
administration has ignored people like
you
you know all i've been asking uh this
administration and prior administration
is to listen
to the people that live on the border we
don't just come and visit for a few
hours we actually live there
there are people there with so much
experience the border sheriffs the
police
chiefs the mayors and the judges and we
know
how the border works we understand the
dynamics we understand what happens on
the mexican side
like your reporter said most of the
property or the territory on the other
side
of the border is controlled by drug
cartels
nobody goes in nobody crosses without
them
charging them and giving them the opaque
kamala harris has been charged with
leading the response
it's been 71 days since she was
appointed to that position
back to the question why is this
administration ignoring people like
you well you know
again it's something that you know we
certainly encourage
uh the vice president the president come
visit uh the border
i think it's important uh but i guess
they'll do it on their own
time and terms but certainly at the same
time when we're doing that
i sit on the appropriations i got folks
that on the border that we serve the
appropriations
and we have a list of proposals to add
for example more
hsi officers the homeland investigators
so they can go
after those criminal drug cartels not
only
the us but go into the foreign countries
and go after those
uh drug cartels because if you don't
stop the money
you know what they charge six eight
thousand dollars depending
without the money they're left it's an
you saw the images of these people that
were drowning in the river they were
saved overnight
our fox cameras caught that uh
apparently a drone caught a woman being
assaulted just on the mexican side of
the border
then you had this five-year-old boy
yesterday in the middle of the night
crying out for help
and pleading with smugglers not to leave
him alone
it's stunning stuff why is 71 days
acceptable well you know
again and what we're seeing at the
border is only a snapshot of what
happens to these people
imagine the hundreds of miles that they
go
uh without any u.s intervention like we
have here at the border
imagine what happens to them and when
they're doing the dangerous trek
for medusa salvador through mexico
imagine what happens to the people that
get raped get assaulted
uh you know including adults and young
kids
we we only we only see a snapshot we
don't see what's happening
in those countries we've got to do
something
henry cuellar thank you for your
agreement a democrat thank you so much
we'll talk again very soon unfortunately
it's been going on for far too long
jillian